my
[Music]
located baby eagles
uh
[Applause]
i guess you me
paid the wrong spot to vacation eh
you will receive our most sacred body
it begins
now
if i could just forget what happened
that night
the pain even for a second
this time
it can be different
it has to
hi everyone i'm yasuhiro
director of resident evil 4
and i'm yoshiaki hirabayashi producer of
resident evil 4
this title is a reimagining of resident
evil 4 based on the original 2005
release
similar to other titles in the series we
are carefully preserving what makes the
original title special while updating it
with modern flourishes for everyone to
enjoy when it launches in 2023
today we'll reintroduce a bit of the
game's story
resident evil 4 is set six years after
the events in raccoon city depicted in
resident evil 2 and resident evil 3. the
main character of the game leon s
kennedy survived the raccoon city
incident and was assigned as an agent
directly under the president of the
united states leon is dispatched to a
quiet village in europe as part of a
mission to rescue the kidnapped daughter
of the president
you might notice leon is much more
mature and fearless due to his past
experiences
the gonado the main enemies of this game
wait for him
the experience of being attacked by
hordes of crazed gennado is truly an
iconic moment from resident evil
in order to truly bring out the concept
of terror of people controlled by
madness the gonado have been completely
redesigned
let's take a closer look
at the game itself
the over-the-shoulder camera returns of
course
leon arrives at a dense and dangerous
forest
we want to nail the feeling of
loneliness and fear of not knowing what
lies ahead even more so than the
original
of course
there will also be thrilling battles
people that played the recent resident
evil 2 and resident evil 3 should find
this familiar
look forward to future announcements
where we'll have more information on the
game
resident evil 4 is being developed for
playstation 5 xbox series x series s and
pc
the release date will be march 24th 2023
we are aiming to create a resident evil
4 that everyone can enjoy so please look
forward to it
thank you
thank you so much
you